What is a mirror?
Speaking in strictly literal terms, it’s
a reflective pane of glass that we use to
check our hair or the clothes we’ve decided
to wear.
Seriously, how did you match that shirt with
those pants?
But think about it another way, what is a
mirror for?
Well, it’s for showing us ourselves, allowing
us to see what everybody else around us does
when they look in our direction.
In that way, you could say that a mirror is
honest.
A mirror doesn’t lie, but that doesn't mean
they can’t hold secrets behind that looking
glass.
Also known by the alternate name of the Red
Sea Object, SCP-093 is not a mirror itself,
it’s actually a red disc that has been carved
from cinnabar.
Cinnabar, for anyone not already aware, is
a toxic ore of mercury, that has been crafted
into jewelry and ornaments in many parts of
the world over the centuries, thanks to its
ruby-like red coloration.
The SCP-093 disc itself is only around 7.62
cm in diameter, fitting comfortably in most
average-sized palms.
All around the object are a number of symbols
carved into its surface, strange circular
engravings of unknown origin.
The color of the red stone disc will also
apparently change based on whatever regrets
are being carried by the person who holds
it.
There seems to be some link between color
changes and the mental state or level of knowledge
possessed by the subject.
To put it in much simpler terms, think of
SCP-093’s color like one of those novelty
mood rings you see in gift shops, that change
to different hues supposedly to match a person’s
mood - although in actuality, it’s normally
changed by their body heat.
The same cannot be said of the Red Sea Object:
It is stunningly accurate in peering into
your soul and diagnosing the darkness within.
If ever you come into contact with this baby,
you might even discover that it knows you
better than you.
So, a weird, stone disc, doesn’t sound all
that impressive, does it?
And what does that have to do with mirrors?
Well, SCP-093 happens to have a certain attachment
to mirrors, and we mean that very, very literally.
If the Red Sea Object is ever not in front
of a mirror, or not being held by someone,
it will speed towards the closest reflective
surface.
As it rolls its way in the direction of the
nearest mirror, or mirror-like surface, SCP-093
is capable of building up phenomenal speeds,
although curiously it never appears to cause
any impact damage when it finally arrives,
neither to itself nor the mirror it latches
on to.
Which brings us to the next inevitable question,
what happens when SCP-093 is placed on or
attaches itself to a mirror?
Does it create a copy of the person who last
touched it, a clone that reflects all the
darkest parts of someone’s personality?
Maybe it can allow the holder of SCP-093 to
themselves become like a mirror, bending light
away from their body in order to become functionally
invisible?
Well, it’s actually neither of these.
The truth is far more strange and existential.
During extensive testing, the SCP Foundation
investigated the potential anomalous uses
for SCP-093, paying especially close attention
to how the Red Sea Object interacted with
mirrors.
After a number of unsuccessful tests, they
finally learned what happens when someone
places the disk onto a mirror: they move into
the mirror.
Any mirror that SCP-093 is placed against
or otherwise attaches itself to is transformed
into a portal of anomalous origin and destination.
Naturally, the first instinct of the Foundation
personnel examining this artifact is to send
through an expedition to explore the other
side of this newly-formed mirror portal.
So, that’s what they did.
They gathered up a member of D-Class, the
imprisoned criminals that the Foundation uses
as expendable subjects for dangerous tests.
The subject was given water, ready to eat
meals, a flashlight, a gun, and a concealed
knife, the latter of which the D-Class was
not made aware of.
The first subject, despite having a past of
murder and attempted suicide, seemed to regret
his actions and willingly agreed to cooperate
with testing, and as a result, SCP-093 emitted
a blue glow, that also tinted the view in
the mirror.
Perhaps, on the other side, he expected to
meet his end, and expected it as a righteous
punishment for his life of sin.
Stepping through the mirror, to the other
side of the looking glass, the D-Class found
himself in an empty field, not another person
or even a single tree in sight.
Traversing forwards, he quickly came across
a section of grass that was barren, wilted,
and dying, in the center of which was a hole.
Climbing in as per Foundation instructions,
the man found only dirt for about a hundred
meters.
But then, something strange happened.
The dirt around him gradually gave way to
a concrete enclosure that the man remarked
stank of something awful.
The room was lit by a series of ceiling light
fixtures, some of which were already broken.
Three doors were positioned on either side
of the enclosure, with an extra door at the
far end, blocked by some fallen metal shelving.
The existence of a place like this seemed
to imply that someone, was present beyond
the portal.
Or at least, they had been.
This ancient underground bunker, lost to time,
seemed to have traces that people had once
lived there.
In one of the adjacent rooms, the ceiling
seemed to be coated in a smelly, brown sludge.
But it was in here that the D-Class discovered
a makeshift cot, wooden crates containing
foodstuffs and empty water bottles, and a
book lying next to the cot.
When he attempted to approach the book, he
was assaulted by a screeching noise like grinding
metal.
The door was beginning to close.
As the D-Class dashed out, the bodycam he’d
been fitted with seemed to pick up a figure,
standing at the end of the corridor where
the seventh door was.
It opened the door from behind, just a crack,
looked in, and silently shut it once more.
Finding only crumpled newspapers and food
rations, the Foundation ordered the intrepid
D-Class to return to the mirror.
Suddenly, something tugged at the lifeline
secured around his waist; something was pulling
him up out of the tunnel.
While trying to get back to the mirror, the
D-Class witnessed a group of thirty-seven
figures, all of them faceless, with no discernible
features to speak of.
In his escape, he opened fire with the gun
he’d been issued, but not at the crowd,
at something bigger.
A massive humanoid creature, around fifty
times bigger than an average person, was crawling
around on the ground.
Like the other figures, this giant was without
a face, pulling itself towards the mirror
as the D-Class was reeled back through the
mirror by a cable and pulley.
After their first glimpse into the world within
SCP-093, naturally, the Foundation were curious
to learn more.
The next test revealed more about this other
reality, for one, that the Red Sea Object
seemed to choose its locations based on the
personal history of whoever was traveling
through a mirror.
This time, it was a female D-Class, who had
killed two children whilst stealing a car.
She arrived at a farmhouse, which had a bunker
of its own, like the first test.
Much like then, there were definite signs
that someone had inhabited the bunker before
her arrival, but most telling were the three
skeletons and empty revolver.
It seems that everyone in this world lived
in bunkers at some point, possibly to hide
from the various faceless creatures that roam
the landscape.
Additionally, any remnants of a civilization
that were uncovered seemed to fit the aesthetic
of the 1950s, however, this civilization also
seemed to have technology comparable to that
found in the 21st century.
The D-Class discovered a laptop, the casing
of which also seemed to resemble a fifties
style.
Booting the machine up revealed the final
moments of its operating system, something
called “Faithful OS.”
Instances of the same operating system seemed
to crop up everywhere the more the Foundation
sent expeditions through the mirrors.
The world that SCP-093 had offered access
to seemed to be brimming with advanced technology,
far more impressive inventions than anything
that exists in our world.
Not just computers either, but this world
even had functional self-driving cars!
Suck on that, Elon Musk!
And yet, even with all that advancement, they
were still stuck in the fifties, 1953 to be
exact, as one expedition discovered that was
the last recorded year of this world.
But something had clearly occurred here, some
sort of devastating event that had wiped out
almost all of humanity and driven the survivors
into underground bunkers where they eventually
perished.
But what?
The sudden arrival of those faceless creatures?
Or was it more to do with that strange, viscous
brown sludge that seemed to be cropping up
all over the place?
This world seemed to be abundant with religious
imagery, even down to the naming of Faithful
OS.
Symbols of hands clasped together in prayer
and other iconography linked to Christianity
could be found everywhere, from the outer
sides of buildings, to the computers and folders
found when the Foundation expeditions delved
deeper into the cities and offices.
In one, they discovered a waiting area assumed
to be connected to a doctor’s office, which
provided more clues as to just what had happened
here.
Examining the contents of the receptionist’s
computer in this office revealed that the
doctors of this world were deeply ingrained
in theology, and were responsible for treating
their patients for a number of strange symptoms.
One entry described a woman, ‘Citizen Jennifer
McZirka’, who seemingly suffered ‘a lapse
of the heart’.
This apparent condition caused her to sin,
committing adultery before she was admitted
“into the Lord's and our hands for cleansing
of mind and body.”
It appeared that this world took religion
to an extreme, employing doctors to cure sinners
of their trespasses through the use of something
referred to as ‘The Lord’s Tears’; that
brown fluid splattered all over this mirror
world.
This substance, as the Foundation soon learned,
was harvested from the giant faceless creatures
that roamed freely around this place, but
the question still remained: why?
The answers were uncovered in another expedition,
this time by a Foundation service technician
who was able to make SCP-093 turn a bright
red color when he affixed it to a mirror.
He was transported to a room with a rotating
pillar, with beams of light that shone upon…
other copies of SCP-093.
These various copies of the mirror portal
system seemed to be leading to other mysterious
worlds.
As if looking back behind the curtain, the
technician found an adjacent room filled with
computer equipment, monitoring these other
worlds, and categorizing them as either ‘Clean’,
‘Unclean’ or ‘Lost’.
So, what do we have?
Where does all of this leave us besides scratching
our heads?
Clearly, some sort of cataclysmic disaster
occurred in one of these mirror worlds.
It had once been a place where technology
had boomed in the 1950s, but that was also
steeped in deep religious beliefs, to the
extent where sinners were treated with a strange
substance extracted from those faceless creatures.
It seems as if some time ago, a god-like being
known only as Him, arrived in one of these
worlds and this served as the catalyst for
such an advancement in technology.
However, He had also deemed this world to
be Unclean and full of sin, mandating a purge
of all sinners in order to cleanse the world.
As a result, a holy war took place to determine
who was worthy of salvation.
A deeply religious society formed around the
arrival of Him, and their primary weapon against
the sinners was the brown liquid, His Holy
Tears.
And those monsters prowling around?
One part of the Unclean, their Sins given
form.
Except none of that was true.
There never was a war, no fight between holiness
and cleanliness.
The truth was this being, this eldritch abomination
had arrived to conquer.
Using the disks, like SCP-093, he traveled
to that world, fed them lies, and turned the
people into his followers, becoming the master
of their world and eventually its destroyer.
Ultimately, SCP-093 is a warning, a look at
what happens when a being like this takes
over.
The broken, dead world that the Red Sea Object
transports us to is a legacy of His destruction,
a false god preying on humanity and their
beliefs like a theological predator.
Then, when His work is done, He moves on to
find a new world to conquer.
We can only hope that his gaze never rests
upon ours, or that what the Red Sea Object
knows of our many sins will be the least of
our problems.
Now go check out “SCP-2317 - The Devourer
of Worlds / A Door to Another World” and
“SCP-001 - The Black Moon” for more monsters
we definitely don’t want to enter our dimension!